[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm confident kisum and
this is the show for you if you're bored
with people arguing on the internet over
subjects they know nothing about a
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts are fantastic
guests this week you might recognize if
you came to see my Edinburgh show he's
an American journalist and you know
welcome to trigonometry it's pleasure to
be with you well thanks for coming
listen for anyone who doesn't know you
which is an increasingly small number of
people these days just tell us who are
you how are you where you are what's
been your journey through life
most recently became infamous on or
depending on the audience famous for the
for being the victim of an auntie for
beating a robbery in Portland Oregon I I
cover demonstrations there quite
frequently and it was on the 29th of
June that I was attacked and part of
that was caught on video and I was left
with a brain injury from that attack and
we're now as of this recording over two
months since that incident and hasn't
been a single arrest and one of the the
arguments that was that was used by some
people inexplicably to me to defend
these people beating you up was the euro
right-wing and that somehow entitles
people to beat you up
as a journalist so and you have said
that you are right of censor so I I
wanted just to explore what that means
not that that would in any way justify
anyone attacking you of course so where
are you politically I'm just curious
yeah it was Joe Rogan who who asked me
if there was I think he asked if there
was a gun put out your head and you had
her answer how would you that was the
first time I said writer Center I think
I've avoided labels for a long time but
I guess if I had to pick I picked what I
said because the positions that I have
that are important to me I think have
been more so aligned with the right at
least in the American context for
example very unpatriotic I'm very
thankful that the United States provided
refuge
to my parents through political refugees
and in the US and others concede that is
seen as a conservative or right-wing
position to have gratitude for
citizenship and thanking America for
what it is for the freedoms that it
protects right so there's that it's
there's also my parents experience with
escaping communism makes me not have the
luxury of viewing an tyfa and other
revolutionary far-left movements with
the same rose-colored glasses so I am
very critical of anti far as anybody
follows my work knows and I've written
critically about Marxism as well so just
because of I would say it's those two
main things are it's been easy for
people to leave label me as a
conservative writer it took being
charitable there being more the more
trying to delete it delete deal
legitimize me or smear me though say
that I'm a far-right person
so you mentioned about auntie auntie for
something that I've only recently become
aware of who are antifa and what what do
they want to achieve it's a movement
that began in Europe particularly in
Germany in the years post-world War two
the subculture that it goes out of is
anti races punk scene and the American
version of it is as we know today very
very recent for not phenomenon so I have
much more knowledge on the US version of
it compared to the the older German or
Western European versions in the u.s. it
it's had some type of presence in some
progressive cities like Portland since
the 2000s but he became a much more
mainstream things from 2016 going
forward I mean you know just rewinding a
few years nobody expected Donald Trump
to win in Portland is a extremely
progessive said he its I explained to
outsiders that it's basically what the
SG sjws X and ethos of a university
mainstreamed into entire city into city
government so we have three days of
protests devolved into rioting in
November 2016 and that was the first
time that I saw black bloc anti-fur they
were going around in their mass and
black outfits and destroying property
and starting fires in the street and
because Trump continues to be such a
polarizing figure and a lightning rod
for fear-mongering on the left him and
his administration has been a very
powerful propaganda win for antiphon so
now they are able to point to him or
various things and his his policies or
things that are done in his
administration as evidence of a sudden
and rising fascism and it's pulled in a
large number of people I mean it's still
a fringe movement but it's grown now to
a point where the city and the public
can no longer ignore so that's why
footage in Portland keeps going viral of
these brawls on the street that look
almost comical from it you know if
you're watching the videos they look
outrageous but like people innocent
people regular citizens get caught up in
it and it's on my perception that
because of the the political monoculture
of the not just the citizens but those
who are in government that it seems like
they're turning a blind eye to far less
violence and Portland's political
structure is unique in that our mayor is
also a police commissioner so you can
see the conflict of interests and he's
up for reelection and so there's just
all these variables coming together of
is what you see what cause kind of what
happened to me and I wasn't the only
victim there's been others before me
there'll be those after me and
just through the course of my speaking
up about the far-left militancy that's
happening not just in my city but in the
that particular region of America the
Pacific Northwest I've been targeted
quite a bit in the last wing media and
before we touch on what happened to your
assault what what is it that they want
to achieve as a socialist do they want
to overthrow the government institution
and putting an assumption this
government are they communists but what
what are they
aunty fire is a movement I don't ever
describe them as an organization in some
people because they're not too informed
and it describes them as a a group
they're not it's it's an ideology that
is made up of many groups and some of
them are ad hoc so you know it could be
something as a group Anti Fog group that
forms in opposition to an event that's
happening a certain weekend or a
conference or something that they oppose
Portland is a bit different that we do
kind of have a in ante for organization
called row city antipholus been around
since 2007 and they have a Twitter
Facebook and online store so so they
operate much more as a formal
organization and they were the ones who
claimed responsibility for my attack
what they it's a movement made up of
well under certain truck so this
organization that exists or has a
physical address that has a store right
it's an online online store okay but but
presumably people know we know who they
are right no we don't we don't entirely
anonymous okay track it through a bank
account I imagine if the police were
interested enough they could find out at
least some of the people who are
connected so they claimed responsibility
for beating you up and yet
I presume they haven't been arrested
they haven't been tracked down they
haven't been prosecuted as I right
correct and why is that well yeah I
actually don't know I speculate that
it's because of his lack of political
will in Portland to process
cute anti-fur because they have quite a
lot of support in the city I have my own
legal team that's funded through a legal
fund I was taken on as a client for
Publius Lacs which is a civil rights
nonprofit and it's of my view that my
civil rights were violated in that me
just working as a journalist documenting
things happening in a public space have
been continuing continually attacked and
intimidated and more recently left with
the serious injury and that the policing
tactics don't change and they just
continue allow citizens to get assaulted
and it's through that legal fund and my
legal team that were doing our own
investigations to see what we can find
because it does seem like there are
systemic issues important that it's not
just isolated incidents of of street
violence but I mean this has been going
on for years now
and very very few people ever get held
accountable and that to me just seems so
bizarre and ridiculous because you were
seriously assaulted I mean I don't know
the American term the British time would
say probably GBH grievous bodily harm of
which someone would go to prison for six
months to a year and the fact that there
doesn't seem to be any willingness to
him to investigate a bit have they
opened an investigation about what
happened there's an ongoing
investigation but the important police
aren't keeping me updated on where they
are and the one thing that I found quite
upsetting and I'm on the left is the
lack of sympathy that I saw from people
on the left to what happened to you is
if oh you know he's on the right
therefore he sort of deserves it which I
found to be abhorrent and an absolute
callousness yeah I think like you know
one of your questions earlier was like
what what do auntie for what the it's a
coalition made up of radical extreme
communist and anarchist and though they
really believe that they're at the
vanguard of some revolution that this is
going to be a cosmic battle with the
fascists
and that they are going to be the ones
who will be leading the the anti-fascist
side it's beyond that which sounds
outrageous there's a more coherent
political theory behind it you know my I
focus on anti-fur but I don't think
they're like an exit existential threat
to American democracy or anything and in
the United States as well as this
country have developed democracies
there's no way that a small fringe
movement can take over the country
however that doesn't mean that Anti Fog
can't find success through other ways
and I think what we're seeing in the
u.s. is that one of the goals is really
to normalize political violence and that
used to not be a partisan issue in the
US but now it has become in that there
are many mainstream politicians and
thinkers and commentators on the left
who who have the view that if somebody
has or is accused of having abhorrent
views they must be shut down by any
means necessary and that's actually one
of the anti-fog group's adopt that name
by any means necessary so it can be
through shutting them down to redock
seing them intimidating them through
insulting them and then if need be
something like what happened to me so
there's been a lot of disinformation in
this information about me that have come
from mt4 supporters and they really
accused believe that I am a far-right
threat to them we'll get to that in a
moment on you but actually none of that
matters if you're a journalist even if
you were a right-wing journalist who was
there with to misrepresent part of you
still doesn't entitle people to beat you
up that that's not how to serve a lie
society works and and the biggest
problem of course with all of this is
that if violence is legitimized I want
legitimized by one side what you're then
doing is you're sending a message the
violence is acceptable what do you think
the far the genuine far-right which does
a small fringe what are they gonna do
and as we know they are probably better
at violence than than the far left so I
don't think it in any way it matters
what your political opinions are
actually for for whether this was
legitimate no it's just not legitimate
and you know you talked about it being
comical initially or being seen as
comical by outsiders
I remember watching prior to your
incident footage of these antiva
protesters and Portland blocking of
streets and directing traffic and then
an old guy in his car being kind of he
tried to drive through and he was
assaulted and and all this stuff and the
police standing there at the back just
watching this whole thing and anyone
with any sense could see that that would
then lead to an g4 becoming emboldened
so how much of it is as you say the pill
the lack of political will in the city
that has encouraged these people to feel
like they can run around beating people
up you know if I I mean it would be just
speculation at this point but my
observation is what happens at these
things is these demonstrations as police
will be on the periphery always within
eyesight of sometimes of violence and
things that happen before the violence
so like on May Day what happened to me
was that I had been punched in the
stomach and I reported it immediately to
police who were just several yards away
and there's the response then and I
could still point out the suspect who
was masked but still within eyesight the
response then as it's been every time
inside we will not approach speak to
confront or detain as a suspect because
I could incite the crowd so aunt I found
other far-left militants have been
basically been given a blueprint it's
like if you if we as a mob promised
violence than the police just wanted to
me and that that video that you talked
about that when they shot down that the
traffic in the street that happens was
actually quite routinely important like
it's almost to the point now where like
the violence on the streets is the
banality and
people don't even like just two weeks
ago in Portland there was the city was
bracing for some major demonstrations
and the fact that nobody was killed but
several people were injured that was
seen as a success in the city and it was
described as peaceful which was shocking
to me some of the video you seen of
people taking out concrete and throwing
it a bus that was trying to leave I mean
you know my detractors keep bringing up
that but these are the far-right they're
extreme they're white supremacist
whatever you know what happened that day
is regardless of whatever views these
people have within the bus they were
trying to leave the the demonstration
and they were leaving in the area and
they were prevented from leaving because
traffic was shut down because of people
in the street and then these people
rushed the bus and then there was this
footage with the hammer and them trying
in spraying people spraying bear mace
inside the bus as they were driving off
like to me it's almost like the views
here are irrelevant it's like this
action of this violence where people are
not just condoning it but cheering them
on because it's these people they don't
like these people they don't like on the
bus but how much of how much truth is in
this idea that is essentially two groups
of extremists coming together to fight
each other because the the they they are
whenever I see antifa being written
about in the media is always they are
counter protesters so the setup is that
they are protesting against other people
who've come to Portland to to spread the
hateful far-right ideas how much truth
is that to that there is some truth to
that but more often than not what
happens is a some type of right-wing or
conservative group will announce that
they are holding some type of event in
Portland it can be something as simple
as a small rally or holding American
flags the left-wing activist and
anti-fur will view that as a provocation
in organized to come in to they say
defend our communities but in in the
language of Vanity Fair what that really
means is come to physically confront
them so there's that sometimes what
happens is
that some of the right-wing groups will
go to an event that an tyfa is organized
to in the they would say they're going
there just to watch or listen to observe
peacefully anti-fur views are as a
provocation so I mean it's not like both
sides are equally to blame are both
sides are equally blameless but what I
see is it's more so one side being
unable to accept that there's this small
group of people who have opposing these
who want to speak openly like they can't
tolerate that because they do believe
that their ideas are so dangerous that
if we allow if we give them an inch what
we will have is the Holocaust again
essentially so they use a lot of
language from the interwar years they
adopt the symbols of the empty the
anti-fascist from that time because they
really think that they are part of that
legacy of the from the interwar years in
Europe it's it's delusional it's
outrageous and it would be funny if
innocent people didn't get caught up in
their violence and Andy how much
responsibility do you think Trump needs
to take for the fact that antifa have
grown because of the use of is rhetoric
when in his political rallies refer I
mean referring to people as sons of
[ __ ] Mexican immigrants using the
word rapists and does that not how you
does he you know I have to take some
responsibility for the fact that this
hard left have become emboldened well
aunt EFA's issues is with Trump but
primarily they take it out on his
supporters so you know I mean in in the
US and actually all around the world
we've been discussing for years now
problems with Trump's rhetoric and I
just I don't you know if you're like a
it's the same conversation over and over
like he said something offensive
he said something that he didn't walk
back very well and that was just going
to be angry and upset about it well then
go out to the streets and demonstrate I
think what I appreciate about him
speaking out more now about anti foes
like it's bringing attention more to
this extremist movement you know I of
course at the same time I we all have to
recognize that it's not just his things
that he said but I think his lack of
action in being a good unifier has
driven more this polarization in in
America which in turn does empower
anti-fur as well as fringe elements on
the right and so but I think at the end
of the day it's about holding people
accountable for their own actions rather
than I just think it's too tenuous and
vog and I've been argument to say that
Trump is a route radicalizing figure but
would you not so for instance if you
were so if you're a Latino person and
you live in America you hear him use
those words and you were a young
especially a young man of a certain age
a certain certainly being impressible
would that not radicalize you I can feel
that I would be very angry at it maybe
want to protest against it or get upset
and feel that the American president
does not want to represent me see the
only problem with the argument isn't
Aoife incredibly white right yes they
posted the mug shots of all the people
arrested they're all white oh yeah so so
I understand your argument but it
doesn't seem to be borne out I'm
guessing most of these people the middle
class vegans or whatever you know what I
mean yes there's a demographic Savanti
for at least in Portland well actually
in other cities like DC or Berkeley
would have a predominantly white they
will try to elevate like the few
individuals who the I think they use
them as tokens you know they're trans
person of color or the disabled person
to put them at the front of the line
whereas were black bloc was
behind them I mean it's just for optics
every conference every corporation does
it Republican Democrat and but I mean in
in response to your question I think
there's nothing wrong with dumb ins
protesting that's part of the American
spirit but like what anti fund the
Allies are doing is it's not lawful
protesting it's shutting down the
streets they call it Dirac action
physical confrontations with people and
the label and the type of people that
they you know jet they sometimes do
genuinely go against oppose true
far-right figures but because those
number of people are really small and
they need a constant threat to not only
give themselves meaning but to recruit
other people they've expanded very very
broadly who they consider a fascist or
that's just supporting or Nazi in that
you know now encompasses people like me
for example so it's like and the things
that they do are a criminal and so I
there's a lot too there are many issues
with Donald Trump I don't think that it
that I'm not sure now at this point if
he was just taken out of the picture of
Anti Fog would just go away would be
definitely harder to them to recruit but
many aspects of their ideology or
basically have been mainstreamed by some
of our politicians like a OCE for
example the demonization of law
enforcement the even just dealer just
amazing the concept of sovereignty in
the u.s. so there's been in the past two
months four incidents of immigration
customs enforcement facilities being
targeted and one of them was by an
antiphonal teen in the state of
Washington close to to Portland where
one of the fire bombs of facility tried
to ignite a 500 gallon propane tank and
came down with the rifle he got killed
before he killed
money but he left behind a manifesto I'd
actually crossed paths with him before
so like I thought was massively
underreported it was it was so like the
street hooliganism on the street is one
aspect of it but it's the ideology
itself is very extreme I mean it's it's
like revolution by any means necessary
and we will take up arms and you know
the the shoot the mass shooter in Ohio
recently he didn't leave behind a
manifesto as far as we know but Lisa's
social media footprint can give us a
clue in his views and he was extremely
he was a part of an t fightin that he
attended the demonstrations in his state
expressed support for their views and so
I'm not sure if we can even really say
that anti fighting a lot that there's no
body count on the anti facade anymore I
mean we'll see what the investigation
finds but you know this we don't know
anything about the Ohio shooters
ideology beyond his social media and he
did leave a very extensive history of
support for violent violent militancy
and why do you think because when I said
I was on holiday and I saw both of the
shootings which happen in quick
succession and the first one I thought
it wasn't it was it in Texas yes so the
first one was in Texas and I was having
to a Latin American community
it was awful awful of course it was and
then there was another one that happened
and that didn't seem to get as much
press or that might have been just what
happened in Europe and the way the BBC
presented it because the BBC pushed
forward the one that happened in Texas
and that one it seemed to be swept under
the carpet is that fair to say it for
sure received less attention I mean
there were fewer fatalities in Ohio
shooting but still nine people were
killed us a lot and so I think you know
it's about media narratives it's the
fact that the your pastor shooter in
taxes was targeting Mexicans in he left
behind a manifesto where his ideas
create a easy headlines for example
because he had done a phobic views like
it's much easier to sensationalize that
type of straw and make people go crazy
on social media where's the ohio shoot
who was a bit more complicated in that
he didn't believe i and a right-wing
manifesto in his social media account
certainly didn't show him being
sympathetic to white supremacy an
attempt that and quite the contrary so I
think ideology has a lot to do with that
I mean you see it often when criminal
violent acts are committed by somebody
who is part of a historically
marginalized community there's I think
what journalists they don't want to
focus too much on excel ways afraid of
how it could negatively impact the
perception of the community whereas if
that suspect but criminal is a white man
particularly if he is seen as
potentially conservative anyways and
it's a free-for-all so that's just the
nature of the media in the United States
as well as this country and how much do
you think this is about language because
we've had a number of people on this
show talking about you know in Britain
brexit voters being called Nazis being
milkshake breaks a probe wrecks of
politicians being called not is being
milkshake how much of this do you think
is about the fact that if you keep
calling everyone Nazis there will be
some people who eventually actually
believe it and then I mean look if I
thought that they were genuine Nazis
coming right well I I probably would use
violence to try and defend myself you
know what I mean so how much of it is
about we've we've managed to persuade
ourselves that there's this horde of
Nazis coming for all of us and some of
these people are now buying into that
idea when the reality wouldn't suggest
that
you know I think it would be easier to
for me to step back and just sort of
accept that the nature of of ad hominem
insults is like you know constantly
trying to outdo the other and so like if
Nazis had just remained an insult and
stayed that was used as part of this
rhetoric then that's one thing but what
happens is punch a Nazi became a meme
that was quite celebrated you know like
Richard Spencer is an easy person for
for people to hate but then as I said a
moment ago the definition of Nazi has
become kind of meaningless now and so
it's just applied very very broadly and
there's people now who think well this
person's are Nazi it's okay to punch him
or her right or do something worse so
language has something to do with it but
I think it's more so that the actions
now the response to people you dislike
like shutting them down through violent
talks is seen as acceptable I mean it
was in this country that milk shaking
became this new phenomenon that very
quickly crossed the Atlantic and it was
pretty much universally celebrated by
your chartering classes as well as the
American ones too I mean it was
basically described the American
left-wing poetry as a cute form of
political dissent we can saw how quickly
that that slippery slope right and like
what happened to me that day the milk
shaking served a particular purpose
primarily one to mark me as a target for
everybody else in the crowd because
there are many people who knew my name
and my writings but didn't know my face
so you know that literally yeah it's
like a big arrow direct to me once I
have all that stuff on me and then
secondly it blinds you as well when it
goes in your face and your eyes and you
can't even see so it's very insidious
and I am concerned that there's
like I should really you know in
developed liberal democracies like
political violence should be some things
I was universally condemned but now it's
not it's kind of like you hear a lot of
I don't support violence but these
people are X Y & Z right yeah oh it's
despicable and we talked about at the
time with many people I mean the idea
that you can go around throwing stuff at
people because you don't agree with them
is not what a democracy is and it just
it should be condemned by everybody
irrespective of whether you agree with
the people or not and the fact that a
lot of people felt very comfortable with
that there was deeply troubling to me
just a milkshake in alone what happened
to use obviously incredibly serious and
much more clearly defined but I've
always said that you know milk attacking
someone by throwing the milkshake at
them they don't know what's in that cup
they don't know and so the whole point
of it is you're scaring the person I
mean and they don't know what that
liquid is I could be acid it could be
anything
and of course it's intimidation is
designed specifically to prevent people
from speaking it's political violence
designed to shut down discussion that's
that's what it is but let's talk it
let's let's talk about some of the stuff
that's happened more recently because
one of the things that we we know now is
that there was some criticism of you and
then attempt to present you in a
particular line and I wanted to speak to
you about that and see what you have to
say about it because there was this
video released it's an 18 minute video I
find it quite boring and difficult to
watch but basically if if I can
represent what is being said about it
and then you can say what you think
about it and correct me if any of my
thing is not accurate to what people are
saying right what I think people are
saying is you were part you were walking
together with a right-wing group of is a
pager prayer right who who were planning
to attack a bar in which these anti-fur
people hang out and you were
participating or at least observing a
conversation in which they were planning
this violent attack
and people have used that to essentially
say and Andino is not an objective
journalist what he is is someone who
hates auntie fur so he records all their
violent crimes but when it comes to
right-wing violence which also does
exist he doesn't record that he doesn't
present that and therefore he presents a
skewed picture and they've then gone on
to say that that's why you left Colette
so tell us about that yes so I left call
eight a week before the latest
controversy broke out it was a mutual
decision I'm moving on to other projects
I'm going to be working on a book just
don't have time to continue to be
working with Colette and it's been a
great experience so I'm very thankful
for the time that I've had there those
who dislike me use as we're trying to
link it with the latest outrage this
video that's come out that some headline
subscribers damning and has filled very
serious accusations against me actually
I think criminal accusations of
criminality and that I was party to a
violent criminal conspiracy conspiracy
or had knowledge of it that withheld it
from the authorities it's absolutely all
in truth rubbish this video I actually
encourage everybody to watch it it's
kind of like washing paint dries 80
minutes so that was recorded on the
first of May 2019 May Day
there were series of demonstrations
throughout the day I have been
documenting it it was early in the day
that I have been punched in the abdomen
and sprayed with silly string and so
that happened all before this video
started there was a right-wing
demonstration where they were holding
flags of a bridge and after that was
over they were milling around the street
and walking around I was just following
them it was really uneventful it's
actually quite boring and I was thinking
I was looking at my phone which you can
actually see in the video one to see how
the other journalists had covered the
protests from earlier in the day so does
anything else that I missed because it
was happening at different
the city and I was trying to see if
anybody had caught video me getting
assaulted so that's what I was looking
at and concentrated on I only heard
schnitz snippets of what these people
are talking about and none of it to me
was interesting was like where are we
going to go is anybody else joining us
what's going on like so I didn't record
that it wasn't and I mind you I need to
point out I wasn't only photojournalist
I was there there are three other people
including a local left-wing journalist
by the way so none of us found I knew
this interesting there was at one point
where people have said some of the
headlines have been completely false
demonstrably false if you watch the
video it's saying that I lost while
people were planning a an attack I never
left in the video there's a one point
where I did give a faint smile I recall
them saying something about how they
were really outnumbered and I was just
at that time thinking about like this is
why you know they're always outnumbered
10 to one if they're lucky like this is
the futility of their demonstrations in
progressive Portland and that was spun
as me being improving or supportive of
whatever happened next
and I don't think it was apparent to any
of us there what was going to happen
next because even this this video who
was reported by an undercover anti-fur
activists someone who had been
undercover for two years and this is
like the climax of his work right one it
was selectively released in that he
doesn't show any any of what happened
actually out the anti-fur pub that was
hosting the anti foot party doesn't show
any of that and that that was whereas I
was seriously assaulted there as well
and so he loveed accusations against me
anonymously
it's an unverified well one is an
anonymous person so it's unverified
source and that it the fact is this he
was interviewed and it went on a on the
left wing blog and called the Portland
mercury which is also a paper
and you know it's like this whole like
watching myself being smeared in real
time and made until somebody or not has
been really fascinating kind of surreal
it's like seeing how it's a game of
telephone ominous like this and all the
players are you know the the writers a
HuffPo box or vice and then all the
Twitter checkmarks people who kind of
parted the same left-wing Scorchers
partisan ideological right writers and
it was just like Oh some decide and he
was laughing when when he did Andy's
laughing in a damning video let's repeat
on the headlines and over and over over
and it just you know they really depend
on people not watching it what happened
next on in that video is well I went to
the bar and and actually in an interview
with this anti anonymous interior
activist he stopped recording at one
point not to call the police but to call
the people out the ante for party you
know so if this was if he was really
witnessing a violent criminal conspiracy
I wonder why he didn't call police and
this video footage even at the very end
of the interview he said he didn't
realize what he had caught until much
until sometime later before releasing it
so it wasn't apparent to him and he was
right there talking to the people and I
was walking around the area sometimes
close mostly far away as well as being
concentrated with things on my phone
okay so just to be clear what you're
saying is at no point did you feel that
these people were about to go and attack
someone in a bar I didn't have a full
picture that would have led me to that
conclusion correct
and Andy do you think we're entering
this really dangerous period not for
journalism where every journalist and
every journalist that publication seems
to be advocacy journalism and that
people just want to push their narrative
and they will twist the facts in order
to suit their our narrative and actually
what happened the facts
nobody seems to care about anymore yes
you know and I need to you know self
introspection
is very important to me and integrity
and all that so I need to point out that
not everything that the critics say
about me are wrong some of it has merit
for example just the nature of on the
ground breaking news reporting with
things that I have many things happening
at the same time sometimes in that very
moment you may get a detail wrong you
don't have the advantage of the multiple
angles that come out in the hours later
and of course you know the basically the
crowdsourcing of that checking of
something rahama thing would be a good
example where the hammer was on the bus
but you may initially mentioned it being
I actually never described where it came
from but in the video you do see that it
at one point one of the people from the
antipholus I did have the hammer I
didn't know that it Richardson came from
inside I came out and corrected the
record for that and then I released a
video that I two days a few days later
that I didn't have access to initially
that was like the full-on cuts that
showed you know the group of people
descending on that bus kind of like the
whole like this contacts to that hammer
being taken out you know like you can
make an argument of potentially with
self-defense and if you watched it an
unedited video it was people from the
outside who charged towards the door by
the way so yes there's I had to correct
that there was some other small details
so this is stuff that it's like I mean
relatively small more mistakes that I
correct but then they used to sort of
say that everything I say is a lie and I
you know it's like I'm just one
individual working as a as an
independent journalist a freelance
writer you know you see huge mistakes
being done by people like on MSNBC or
seen and and they have an entire
department of fact checkers and editors
behind them and they still get some
mistakes they start you know it's just
so like taking cheap shots at me like
that I think is disingenuous
particularly when these writers are
either in DC or New York City and not on
the ground employment and seeing and
witnessing what happens I mean you know
it's just it doesn't seem a good faith
argument but you know I there is some
merit to it and that I have gotten
things wrong that I correct but the
other smears that are coming out now
that I am that I coordinate with
far-right people it's it's outrageous so
there was another new story that came
out in the Willamette week which is a
local paper in Portland I am and they
had to obtain a secret recording of I
guess men that were inside that bus I
think I don't know if it was before
after that hammer thing I think was
after so they released that and at one
point one of the men was talking about
how and ego got beat up because he
turned down the proud boys offer of
security hmm and then the the commentary
in a news story not an opinion piece by
the way new story was that this was
evidence of me colluding with the POW
boys and I don't know if I'm it's it's
like I've it's like we're reading and
listening to different things because um
you know there was an outpouring of
support to me after the May Day attack
where I was sprayed with bear mace in
the face and was blinded and that
happened so I had a whole bunch of
people that I didn't know offered to be
volunteers security if I go out and
cover more protests I turn down those
offers because I wanted to maintain my
independence and now that is used as
evidence and coordination so I don't you
know like this whole thing seems like
what through the looking-glass I you
know I feel like I don't know if the
world's going mad or if it's me but it's
like it's amazing that like for me the
victim of multiple multiple assaults in
in in having my dress Docs and part of
the reason I'm in the UK is actually was
because they continue violent threats to
myself I've been reported to police and
I just need to get away far away from
the US
and like me being the victim of all that
is now somehow spun around is I am like
an extreme violent person who is the
aggressor
who deserves all this or was brought it
on myself it's it's almost like a dream
it just it doesn't seem like this is
really reality to me it's scary to me
how many people are delighted about
what's happened I mean I've before our
interview I watched a clip of The Young
Turks and David Pakman both talking
about this and particularly the Young
Turks I mean the way that they try and
present themselves as objective
journalists and then he goes yeah well
conservatives don't feel any empathy and
and it's just like how can you even
pretend to be in any way objective when
you when you talk in that way and
neither of us is conservative we just
try and talk to people who who may we
may disagree with or who may but you
can't you can't talk about people in
that way and then present yourselves as
objective but the they used exactly the
phraseology that you talked about
something along the lines of well of
course violence shouldn't be used but
and and that happened in that video a
couple of times and I was like do you
understand what you're saying anything
you said before the word but doesn't
count you know so obviously there is
there is a large group of people who are
very happy about you being treated in
this way yes why why do they see you're
such a threat do you think because I'm a
decent professional person who has quite
reach in my writings like many people
who have been very critical event if
I've been confined to other blogs or
YouTube videos whereas my writings have
been published in The Wall Street
Journal and the National Review the New
York Post and I was with Colet and so
it's just like and what with what
happened to me in the 29th of June it it
kind of woke up some of the politicians
to start speaking about antipholus
extremism which hadn't been done before
so I I am a perceived as a threat
understandably to them because for so
long they've just been receiving pretty
much
only favorable coverage and the fact
that now there's somebody who's can't be
relied on to provide favorable coverage
consistently who calls him out
interactions and who has a reach that
you know I have quite a large reach on
Twitter my the places that published me
have a large people large amounts of
people reading it it's they see that
their control over the narrative is
slipping a bit and actually they really
depend on that that control over how
they've perceived because their actions
an ideology is so extreme that they
really do have to rely on those who are
willing to whitewash and rationalize the
things they do and once that gets
challenged whoever's doing the
challenging needs to be taken out by any
means necessary Andy I'm you could show
me as being a very bright person the
true sense of the word you your life
could be a hell of a lot easier if you
didn't do this why do you feel the need
as a journalist to put yourself in the
firing line and to put your body on the
line as well I have a lot of journalist
friends who told me and you just move on
to write other things like the pile on
that happens every time you do something
one of these things the the scrutiny on
every single detail every single word
you say like it's just not worth of that
living that type under that type of
pressure and on top of you know the
threats of violence and I think I've
refused to be cowed because the things
that ante has been doing to me for
months is to terrorize me into silence
and I think with the the crowd beating
on the 29th of June that was meant to
like attempt to permanently silent it
silenced me and they failed and I just I
refused to give them that type of
victory you know of course moving
forward I'm much more wise about how I
cover events in that I
I no longer unfortunately no longer
believe that the Portland Police are
willing to uphold the law for example
even if I'm covering out to flood in
right in front of police like I was
naive to think that the police would
actually protect an you know a citizen
just in a public space so there's things
that I'll change but I'm sticking on
this there's other things I write about
that makes people on the far left and a
lot ate me you know I write about hate
crime hoaxes quite a bit that was
originally how I kind of started
receiving some notoriety earlier this
year and that challenges in weakens
anti-fur narrative which is that we are
living in such an oppressive dangerous
time that violence is justified against
the oppressors and the presses can be
anything from regular Trump supporters
to those truly on the far right but
that's I mean that's a huge spectrum of
people that they all oppose with the
same hatred and violence so I'm going to
continue to speak out I recognize and
you know I want to be a better
journalist to the mistakes that I made
that I've had to correct I mean it's
embarrassing every time that happens but
you know any journalist what's integrity
recognizes that and works to improve on
it so you know I have goals that I had
to work on for myself moving forward at
the same time you know when something's
an outright lie against me as some of
these headlines are right now the
outright lies and you know I just like
to say I've my legal team is aware of it
because I think some of the claims
against me rises to the level of by
little libel and defamation well I was
going to ask you you're hidden in London
in England we had something not similar
but we had some protests recently do you
think we're gonna see more of this
across the world
he's running battles between people on
the two extremes the issues that we're
seeing with anti far more recently is
really kind of confined to the
Anglosphere I mean anti-fur activism in
Germany is the kind of entirely
different thing because they actually do
have a history that goes back decades of
this group and some of the ideas that
are from America I notice are bouncing
off to
far less militants in Britain what
happened I was encouraged to see was
that the London Metropolitan Police even
without having any of the heavily
militarized gear that you see American
police ha they were able to contain law
and order for example last weekend when
there was an aunty for demonstration
against Tommy Robinson supporters they
were marching on the street so they had
disrupted traffic and before they could
really do that for much longer the
police just surrounded them in such
large numbers that they couldn't do
anything in the and the police pushed
them to the pavement so they won they
could no longer disrupt traffic some of
them were carrying some small sticks
that had sharpened ends that was taken
and it seemed like because the police
are quick to act they're not emboldened
to see how much he can push because in
Portland it wasn't like right away that
you know they were attacking people on
the street it was like okay first we're
gonna take over the streets and we can
do it secondly some of us are gonna
bring in bats or brass knuckles or small
knives in bear mace and we get away with
it and the next thing is we're gonna
start using it like so you know like the
incidence of political violence in
Britain that I've seen have been much
more isolated and small I mean I know
that some of the controversial political
people who ran as any peas not too long
ago were targeted but like that's the
violence that I saw there wasn't
anything like what we we see continued
to see important so I think that as more
attention is brought to the dangers of
normalizing political violence in
liberal democracies I think police will
naturally face more pressure to do more
unfortunately importantly in our police
commissioner's also our mayor so that
may be the one exception but what I'm
really concerned about it's just that
the wider public will as
and encourage those types of violent
actions because they believe that it's
for a better cause or good cause I think
that's extremely damaging to how
citizens relate to one another it's like
if you erase the line between thoughts
ideas and actions like but I mean there
are many parts of the world actually
were depending on the just the idea that
you hold you can be put to dust for it
either by the state or through a mob
lynching and so it worries me that many
influential people here who have
benefited from the the rights that come
in the civil rights that come in liberal
democracy that they are in a way of
working to weaken those sort of like
those rules that are codified into law
but as well as expected between one
another that's what I'm concerned about
and do you think we're going to be able
to because at the moment I mean maybe
it's just you know the effect of the
internet you look at the internet
everybody seems to be more polarizing
over
you know we seem to be brightening
ourselves into certain camps do you
think that we're gonna be able to heal
this division or do see it just becoming
worse and worse well in your country
you're dealing was bred sick now and it
does seem like it's getting worse and
worse but you have I mean your Prime
Minister was hated as he is by some
people is I also see him doing good
effort to be a unifier in America it's a
bit hard on you know the president you
know that's Trump is Trump that he
hasn't changed a bit from the campaign
days in 2015 and so there going to be
people who will try everything they can
to exploit this polarization because it
benefits some politically
and so I'm a bit more hopeful about
Burton than I am about America and this
for God well I don't want me to do this
before we ask our last question is do
you think Trump's can it really liked it
yes so do i it's interesting all right
well let's do last question no I'm not
happy now so the question that we always
ask Andy is what is a one thing people
aren't talking about but actually we
really should be talking about well this
is sort of the paradoxes a lot of people
talking about social justice extremism
and craziness in the Universities and
American universities example but also
with some campuses in the UK I mean your
Student Union is particularly outrageous
and I think what's not being looked at
in this particular instance is that this
idea those ideas that were formally
confined to certain disciplines in
university they now have outlets to be
mainstreamed across the rest of society
yeah we read the Guardian yeah well
that's it and this is why did we talked
about the contract that I turned and
that's why I turned it down because I'm
going it's gonna bleed into real life
all the social justice stuff is gonna
bleed into real things it's not just
gonna stay at the University because
these people are gonna grow up and
they're gonna become politicians judges
journalists and they're gonna spread all
this crap and that's why I think people
who are saying need to need to stop it
and say something which is what you're
doing so all the best of luck to you
with it
we wish you well take care of yourself
thank you wear a helmet or something at
least if you do go into these places Joe
Rogan said to you you should bring some
big guys with you but you're clearly not
planning to do that are you no you know
I can't reveal my reporting tactics but
there are many ways when you get
creative of how you can cover a
demonstration without necessarily
putting yourself there okay okay he's
going to use drones all right that's a
good idea
you know in Russia this is completely
irrelevant to what we're talking about
but in Russia they use drones to fly
over all the politicians and oligarchs
mansions to show how these people are
living so they infiltrate their whole
thing with the drone and then they do a
whole report about how I told you build
using stolen money oh no you gotta
there's an idea for you anyway thank you
so much for coming on Andy we really
appreciate your time always always
follow Andy we'll put the thing in the
bottom of the video on Twitter he puts
his reporting there follow us at trigger
pod on other social media and we will
see you in a week from now thanks for
watching guys as always subscribe to the
YouTube channel click the bell button
next to subscribe button so you get
notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word